le conseil général de la réunion vous
présente lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais
d
très souvent la plus grosse dépense d'un
foyer c'est le loyer
lorsqu'on est une famille avec enfants
il faut au minimum à trois pièces pour
le confort et le bien-être de tout le
monde mais les loyers sont très chers et
assurer le paiement de son logement avec
des revenus très modestes peut parfois
être très compliqué alors vers qui se
tourner pour trouver des solutions
existe-t-il des logements à des prix
accessibles on en parle maintenant d'un
lien social
depuis maintenant plusieurs années
monsieur robert vit dans cet immeuble de
saint denis avec sa femme et ses trois
enfants
la famille de monsieur robert il se
trouve un peu à l'étroit par manque d
espace et de chambre après avoir discuté
de son problème avec un collègue
ce dernier lui dit qu'il peut bénéficier
d'un logement social
il s'est donc empressé d'obtenir à
dossier auprès de la sdr pourrait
déposer une candidature
je paye très cher le noyer parce que moi
je pas ici sans héros pendant mon revenu
quoi les laisse à tout ça mais je vais
pas être très cher vous avez des enfants
en bas âge vous êtes rsa ya pas de
ressources donc allé là bas c'est pour
cela que j'ai passé au conseil général à
la providence et j'ai parlé mon cas avec
l'assistante sociale et elle a fait les
démarches au niveau des bailleurs
sociaux et en maintenant j'attends ça
changera ma vie parce que l'aja
dans un appartement f3 et dans ma
demande cf 4 j'espère que c'est moins
cher qu'ici espèce est plus jolie qu'ici
ça me soulage parce que c'est moins cher
que dans la en appartements privés les
appartements pour monsieur robert cet
appartement est trop coûteux par rapport
à ses revenus
cela fait maintenant quatre ans qui a
effectué sa demande auprès de la sdr car
il ya énormément de demandes de
logements sociaux
preuve qu'il s'agit d'un véritable
problème à régler pour les réunionnais
même si robert patiente en sachant que
ce futur appartement sera mieux adapté
pour sa famille avec un loyer plus
accessibles comme monsieur robert maryse
rougemont a fait une demande il ya
quelques années
c'est au mois d'octobre qu'elle est
entrée dans son nouveau logement social
à la colline des camélias
depuis qu'elle en a bénéficié elle se
sent beaucoup mieux et elle a pu faire
des économies en effet son loyer en
moins cher elle a pu mieux gérer son
budget mensuel
j'avais des problèmes et il fallait que
l'on vend dès on a vendu la maison
familiale
bien que j'ai envoyé ce n'était pas trop
tôt aux biens pense qu'on était stressé
pour une contre une tension de temps
font stand jette pas la pierre paradis
et de chercher à loyer temps qu'ont
trouvée par ne pouvait pas sortir la
maison que mon mari était malade et
était à l'hôpital
des mots on a fait avec mais j'ai pas de
u2 d'argent et ben
mes enfants à aider un petit peu le pas
au conseil général et mon mari était
wallace idéologique depuis que
j'arrivais ici j'ai eu moins de
difficultés
royer madame rougemont et soulagé depuis
qu'elle s'est installée dans son nouvel
appartement elle l'attendait depuis
plusieurs années et maintenant son
souhait est réalisée malgré une
démographie en pleine croissance est de
moins en moins de terrains
constructibles des logements sociaux se
construisent un peu partout sur l'île
malgré les efforts du département pour
répondre au plus vite aux demandes
l'attendent pour l'obtention d'un
logement est très longue
un problème pris très au sérieux par le
conseil général
car tout le monde doit pouvoir se loger
convenablement 100 m s'employer en péril
à cause de loyers trop chers les
familles réunionnaises attendent souvent
longtemps pour avoir un logement elles
sont jeunes elles font des enfants et il
ya vingt-deux mille demandes de
logements sociaux en attente en même
temps et parallèlement il y a aussi des
logements sociaux dégradés
parce que vieille du parc ancien et il
ya je crois un troisième problème
aujourd'hui les logements sociaux qui
sortent parfois sortent avec des pics
rochère et la famille réunionnaise n'est
plus de 30% de son pouvoir d'achat sur
un logement social c'est encore trop
important alors nous nous voulons aider
les familles soit sur l'accession à la
propriété mais aussi à travers le parc
privé et nous avons une agence qui est
l'agent ce soleil qui aide pour la prise
en compte par exemple de la garantie
locative qu'on doit donner sur le
premier mois avec du parc privé mais sur
les mêmes prix que à logement social
grâce aux solutions proposées par le
conseil général de nombreuses familles
sont relogées dans des appartements
convenable et accessible financièrement
l' agence immobilière soleil apporte une
aide aux personnes en difficulté en leur
proposant un logement par
l'intermédiaire de leurs assistantes
sociales
le conseil général de la réunion vous a
présenté lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais